before people caught on that video game
movies were a terrible idea
experienced the film that proved video
game movies are a terrible idea
Super Mario Bros based on the super
mario brothers video game kinda where's
the rock okay not really at all comes
the film that takes a game about a tiny
plumber who jumps to the right and
really focuses in on the plumbing nice
and fresh face of it
la koo off all these valves I'm gonna
throw it out promise nightmare
these pipes on my service for years
must've been a non-union job not since
World War Z did a movie had less to do
with its source material where King
Koopa is now a hypochondriac
for some reason germs everywhere toad is
a singing hobo you know the law dog shy
guys are these weirdos and [ __ ] suits
Big Bertha is a nightclub bouncer with
rocket boots goombahs are whatever these
things are and Mario refuses to jump
we're gonna get across you can make it I
gotta go feel I'm gonna jump let's do it
come on just have faith Joe it's trust
yo come on unite a jump your Mario dude
let's Larry the only thing you do you
spent your childhood in the Mushroom
Kingdom a game world overflowing with
playful brightly colored environments
instead of all that travel to a bleak
dystopian hellscape known as Dino Hatton
full of random sparks
evil grandma's jurassic park ripoff
strippers that hold disco scene they
hired a whole bunch of strippers and
tons of fungus providers the Shogun is
getting all that fungus out there carrot
da fiddly wound up on this risky rally
let's get outta here for this fungus
stuff each is alive a the fungus just
saved us trust the fungus in a departure
from his usual good decisions watch Bob
Hoskins reprise his role as Eddie from
Who Framed Roger Rabbit
I'll try I'm trying
get out of that [ __ ] jobs only this time
his name is Mario Mario name Mario last
name Mario together with his brother
Luigi Mario is Maya Mario and Luigi Maya
uh they'll have to save the world from
something about another dimension and a
meteor without that piece of meteor
right lays dormant I'll not be able to
merge the dimensions with the help of
this stuff thingy I want you to meet my
father and then this happens
it's real to me
we're merging man the video game was
already surreal enough how much acid of
these filmmakers take
okay all of it all of the acid so
prepare for a movie going experience so
terrible it made less than half its
money back it scared Nintendo into never
making another live-action movie and in
the career of both its directors and
almost killed Bob Hoskins I was stabbed
full-time electrocuted broke a finger
um nearly got drowned life is why I'm
for me still less painful than watching
the actual movie starring John Luigi's
amo donald trump yoshi the creepy
parking garage guy from Ferris Bueller
that guy from all those movies Donkey
Kong and captain Lou albano Super Mario
brother Luigi Mario Daisy you gotta come
with me I need your help
yeah that's not gonna happen be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers this
sandwich is mine and then I'll take a
potato chip and eat it oh I'm not gonna
kill you I'm just gonna hurt you
really really bad I do believe in
fairies I do I do the couch has hidden T
approach with push in cotton-headed
ninny-muggins
they're not going to catch us we are on
a mission from God